vous êtes entraîneur de l'équipe de
france de football et vous avez réussi à
amener la france en finale de la coupe
du monde de 2018
cette finale c'est contre le grand
président de neymar un grand match en
perspective pour commencer félicitations
maintenant il s'agit de gagner cette
finale de la coupe du monde et pour
mettre toutes les chances de votre côté
il vous faut bien choisir les onze
joueurs qui vont débuter cette finale
alors disons qu'après pas mal de
réflexion vous avez réussi à choisir dix
des onze joueurs mais pour le poste de
milieu défensif
vous hésitez entre le puissant ngolo
comté et le grand adrien radio va
supposer que vous hésitez tellement vous
êtes tellement conscient de l'étendue de
votre ignorance que vous préférez alors
confié aux statistiques vous dites alors
qu'une bonne mesure de l'impact d'un
joueur consiste tout bêtement à regarder
si l'équipe gagne plus souvent lorsque
le joueur en question joue vous
découvrez alors que l'équipe de france
gagne 50% de ses matchs lorsque kanté
est titulaire mais qu'elle gagne 80 % de
ces matches qu'en radio est titulaire
pas d'hésitation go pourra bio si vous
laissez votre organisme sportif de côté
j'imagine que cette petite histoire ne
devrait pas vous choquer vous êtes sûr
que ça nous choque pas oui je fais une
pause anormalement longue
juste pour être sûr que tout va bien
juste avant d'écrire le nom de radio sur
un fait de match vous fait la remarque
que le brésil c'est pas n'importe quelle
équipe
or dans les statistiques en question il
y a beaucoup d'adversaires qui était de
petite équipe vous classez donc les
anciens adversaires de l'équipe de
france en deux catégories les petites
équipes et les grandes équipes contre
les petites équipes avec kant et la
france gagne 100 % de ce match alors
qu'avec rabiot la france en gagne 90 %
oui mais tout ça ne vous concerne pas
vraiment vous allez jouer contre le
brésil
du coup la ligne qui vous intéresse
c'est celle des taux de victoire contre
les grandes équipes avec kant et le taux
de victoire n'est plus que de 40 % mais
avec rabiot la france ne gagne que 10%
de ces grands matches dès lors
clairement il faut sélectionner crantée
mais là vous devrez sauter au plafond et
vous dire ouais mais oui voici bel et
bien les chiffres que vous venez de lire
radio a bien un meilleur taux de
victoires que quand tu es mais quand et
s'en sort mieux contre les petites
équipes et contre les grandes équipes
comment est ce possible comment est ce
possible que radio fasse mieux que quand
tu es sur le global mais que pour tout
adversaire radio semble faire moins bien
que quand tu es avec nous clairement ou
peut-être pas y aurait-il une
explication cohérente de cet étrange
paradoxe
je vais laisser ce paradoxe à l'écran
pendant deux minutes histoire que vous
preniez le temps d'être saisi par la
bizarrerie de ces chiffres et que vous
mettiez pause pour longuement et
réfléchir vraiment n'était pause et
prenez le temps de la réflexion
l'explication du phénomène est
accessible à tout élève de cm1
il n'y a pas besoin de connaissances
avancées pour le comprendre mais cette
explication est potentiellement
extrêmement difficile à trouver
j'ai posé une variante de ce problème à
des élèves en master ça veut dire date
puis cinq et ils ont mis plus de cinq
minutes à trouver
donc si vous galérez c'est parfaitement
normal mais ça ne veut pas du tout dire
que vous ne pouvez pas trouver
l'explication du paradoxe mais ça vaut
vraiment le coup que vous trouviez la
réponse par vous même c'est comme ça que
l'on progresse en mathématiques c'est en
résolvant les problèmes par soi même et
non pas en apprenant par coeur le cours
qui vous est donné surtout qu'une fois
que vous aurez vu la solution vous allez
dire mais bah oui bien sûr et vous allez
oublier la difficulté du problème et
vous n'allez rien retenir bref mettez
pause et réfléchissent easy au moins 5
minutes
n'hésitez pas même à y réfléchir trois
jours s'il le faut vous verrez si vous
arrivez à résoudre ce prime va y avoir
un déclic soudain dans votre cerveau
puis vous devrez avoir une montée
d'adrénaline incroyablement jouissif
résoudre ce genre de problème c'est
ressentir la vraie joie de faire des
mathématiques
n'hésitez pas aussi à en parler à des
amis la joie des mathématiques
ça se partage est ce que j'aime
particulièrement partager c'est
l'étendue de mon ignorance surtout
concernant des preuves dont je pense
qu'il existe une solution trouvable mais
dont je n'ai pas encore trouvé cette
solution est cette énigme ça en est un
parfait exemple
cette énigme est l'une de mes énigmes
préférez donc savourer la surtout tant
que vous ne connaissez pas la solution
est bon on parle de foot là mais bien
sûr le problème reste tel quel si vous
changez non c'est y compris lorsqu'on
aborde des sujets qui éveille
l'hooliganisme en nous comme la santé
les inégalités raciales ou la politique
dans sa forme générale
le problème consiste à expliquer
pourquoi si on considère à hénon a à la
fois alors x est moins bon que y
alors même que xl meilleur pourra et il
est meilleur pour nom à x est alors
meilleurs qu'eux y pour à epône on a
mais pas pour high non à ce troc com par
dax j'adore ce paradoxe c'est ce qu'on
appelle le paradoxe de simpson et si
vous en connaissez l'explication pas de
spoil
je supprimerai les spoils dans les
commentaires allez je vous laisse encore
cinq secondes
bon alors la réponse
c'est quoi eh bien je vais troll est un
peu et ne pas vous donner la réponse à
cette énigme parce que je suis sûr qu'il
y en a qui n'ont pas me pose du coup
vous donnera la réponse uniquement la
semaine prochaine mais je vais quand
même vous aider à trouver la réponse
en vous parlant d'un tout autre problème
tout aussi fictifs imaginons qu'un
ministre affirme qu'il faille mettre fin
aux échecs scolaires et que pour cela il
faut davantage que financement des
lycées
du coup il parvient à faire passer de
lois mais cette loi ne parvient à
financer que certains lycées
l'année passée les lycéens passent le
bac les chiffres tombent les études
statistiques montrent que le taux de
réussite des lycées subventionné est
alors de 78% alors que le taux de
réussite des autres lycées est de 80 %
le parti de l'opposition est scandalisé
voyez distille subventionner les lycées
est une perte d'argent
cet argent aurait pu être utilisé pour
aider les travailleurs plutôt que de
gaspiller dans l'éducation
ils sont convaincants ces politiques
mais le raisonnement est il juste et
bien il semble statistiquement fonds b
si j'étais un algorithme et si on ne me
donnait que ces chiffres il me
semblerait devoir conclure qu investir
dans l'éducation n'a au mieux qu'un
effet négligeable voire négatif alors 2
% de différence ça fait pas beaucoup
mais imaginons que l'étude soit faite
sur toute la france
si bien que la différence soit
statistiquement significative au sens de
la paix valeur il semble alors
irrationnel de continuer à défendre
l'investissement dans l'éducation
qu'en pensez vous eh bien le gros
problème c'est ce qu'on appelle les
facteurs de confusion
en effet après quelques recherches vous
découvrez que comme vous auriez pu vous
y attendre d'ailleurs les subventions
sont allés essentiellement aux lycées
défavorisés
le chiffre de 78 % c'est donc aussi et
surtout le chiffre des lycées
défavorisés
mais alors ce n'est pas étonnant que ce
chiffre demeure inférieur à 80% les
lycées défavorisés étaient moins
performants avant financements il n'est
pas scandaleux qu'ils le soient encore
malgré quelques financements
supplémentaires
on ne change pas les lycées en un an en
fait pour mieux analyser les données il
faudrait diviser les lycées en fonction
de leur état avant financements avec ce
tableau
cette fois on voit que les lycées
défavorisés gagne à être financés et que
les lycées favoriser gagne aussi à être
financés on parle de stratification des
données
puisqu'au lieu de regarder les
statistiques au global on regarde les
statistiques en fonction de tranches
comparables
je vous laisse vérifier les calculs si
parmi les lycées financer il y à 60000
lycées défavorisés avec un taux de
réussite de 75% et 5000 lycée favorisées
avec 90% alors le taux de réussite des
lycées financer est 78% et de même si
parmi les lycées dont financer il y a
vingt mille lycées défavorisés à 70% et
40000 favoriser à 85% alors le taux de
réussite des lycées non financée à 80%
quand bien même le financement semblent
faire gagner 5 % à chaque strate il fait
perdre 2 % aux statistiques globales
j'ai longtemps pensé que le paradoxe de
simpson n'avait rien d'un paradoxe
en bon élève mathématiques je faisais
les calculs pour vérifier la cohérence
du tableau et jean venait à la
conclusion que le tableau n'avait aucun
paradoxe mathématiques
ah la la comme j'étais ignorant en fait
ce qui est fascinant avec le paradoxe de
simpson
ce n'est pas le fait que le tableau soit
juste ce n'est pas non plus le fait
qu'il semble conduire à deux conclusions
opposées
non ce qui rend ce paradoxe simpson
fascinant fondamentale et surtout
incroyablement piégeux c'est le fait que
bien souvent en dehors des salles de
classe de mathématiques
les données du tableau sont vides voire
inconnus le vrai paradoxe simpson c'est
le fait que les données ne nous
indiquent pas quels sont les facteurs de
confusion en pratique 99% du temps
la seule chose qui nous est présenté ce
sont les statistiques globales hors 99%
du temps ces statistiques globales ne
reflète pas du tout le raisonnement
stratifié pourtant indispensable pour
vraiment comprendre le phénomène
statistiques en jeu et 99% du temps nos
cerveaux de primates n'imagine même pas
qu'il puisse y avoir des facteurs de
confusion on a alors tendance à sur
interpréter les données présentées et a
arrêté notre jugement
quand bien même à cause des facteurs de
confusion il serait beaucoup plus
raisonnable
de suspendre notre jugement c'est pour
ça que les statistiques et l'analyse de
données sont des disciplines
incroyablement piégeuse et fascinante
pour bien analyser les données
il est en fait indispensable d'inclure
dans le raisonnement des notions qui
sont complètement absentes des données
en particulier l'empirisme naïfs qui
consisterait à uniquement faire
confiance aux données est voué à la
surinterprétation et à l'échec
pour bien résonner les données ne
suffisent pas il faut aussi absolument
disposer de modèles et de théorie
crédible et il faut parfois faire
davantage confiance aux théories
coodonnées d'ailleurs historiquement
tout le génie de galilée que l'on
présente parfois à tort comme le père de
l'empirisme c'est justement d'avoir
compris intuitivement toute l'importance
des théories en particulier s'il a
réussi à énoncer la loi de la chute des
corps c'est avant tout malgré les
données et c'est surtout en vertu d'un
facteur de confusion dans les données
oui les objets plus ou retombent plus
vite mais ce n'est pas de leur faute
c'est la faute aux facteurs de confusion
que sont les frottement de l'air bref je
pense personnellement que le paradoxe de
simpson et les facteurs de confusion
sont des notions absolument
indispensable à comprendre que ce soit
en sciences en épistémologie oise et
éthiques
or malheureusement à part peut-être dans
les filières d'épidémiologie il en
profite pour vivement recommandé la
chaîne risque alpha qui montre très bien
toutes les subtilités des statistiques
les facteurs de confusion sont souvent
peu ou mal enseignée en cours de
statistiques
le statisticien larry wassermann
écrivait ainsi que le paradoxe de
simpson est très déroutant pour de
nombreuses personnes y compris des
statisticiens bien éduqué je le sais à
titre personnel j'ai mis des années à
comprendre son importance et sa
subtilité pire en 2012 j'ai moi même
enseigne et les cours de statistiques en
université et je n'ai même pas mentionné
ces notions d'une part parce qu'elle
n'était pas au programme
et d'autre part parce que je ne les
connaissais pas oui j'étais un
enseignant de statistiques qui
ignoraient le paradoxe le plus important
des statistiques
or ce paradoxe est vraiment crucial à
connaître il affirme qu'à cause des
facteurs de confusion x peut être
globalement meilleures que y
alors que x est toujours pire que y
ça c'est sans doute le truc le plus
important à retenir d'un cours de
statistiques là
parler du théorème fondamentale des
avantages aux statistiques et notamment
du cadre fréquente est sur lequel ce
théorème propose et j'avais pas mal de
critiques et les hypothèses sous
jacentes du frais kantisme et ça fait
réagir notamment risque alpha faut
savoir que tristan de riscal faena temps
de la statistique a expliqué micha sont
plutôt fréquents piste en tout cas ce
qui semble dire sur twitter tu cause
d'une certaine manière j'attaquais un
petit peu leurs positions et leurs
hypothèses en fait de travail ne s'est
pas tout à fait le cas c'est toujours
plus compliqué que cela
mais ce sur quoi j'ai environ 1 6 tc que
leur réaction est vraiment trop cool ils
sont pas du tout en mode de hooligans
vexé notamment parce qu'ils y voient
l'intérêt scientifique de la réflexion
de vidéos précédentes qui est valable
qu'en soient fréquentes israéliens ou ce
que vous voulez bon bien sûr comme vous
pouvez y atteindre je vais taper un
petit peu plus sur le free kantisme dans
de futurs vidéo mais ce sera pas pour
tout de suite et surtout certains pas du
tout une attaque personnelle des
frigoristes je pense qu'il ya des
hypothèses que l'on fait dans ce cadre
de pensée et que peut-être il ya moyen
de proposer de meilleurs hypothèses et
de meilleurs outils pour répondre à ces
hypothèses mais au final ça c'est
vraiment la preuve des fréquentes east
j'ai envie de dire puisque en
particulier les fréquentes east et en
particulier nathan et tristan sont
extrêmement conscient de tous les
problèmes qu'il peut y avoir dans une
analyse trop simple des données et en
particulier ce paradoxe de simpson c'est
vraiment la spécialité en vue d'élire de
riscal passait vraiment se gagne pain
c'est ce avec quoi ils travaillent tous
les jours et je pense qu'il est bien
meilleur que moi pour comprendre ce prêt
mais pour le résoudre en tout cas je
vous recommande très vivement leur de
chaînes par exemple sur la vidéo tu vois
du light ait été foutu de la statistique
expliquer mon chat tout ça ce sont des
excellentes vidéo que le supporter a pas
de son consentement de la très grande
qualité
c'est pas parce que je critique
certaines hypothèses que font dans
certains cas certains chercheurs et
parce que je pense que ces hypothèses
sont généralement valable mais pas tout
le temps que je critique toutes leurs
positions peu du déjà en fait sa
discussion entre en gros le monde des
statistiques et le monde du machine
learning quelque chose d'absolument
fascinant mais extrêmement difficile
également parce qu'on n'a pas les même
terminologie j'ai eu l'occasion pardon
d'assister à des séminaires qui était en
gros des cours de traduction entre le
langage des statisticiens et le langage
du machine learning typiquement les
phishers et les liposomes j'ai pas mal
parlé dans des épisodes précédents
ça correspond aux notions de variables
expliqué et explicative dans le langage
des statisticiens il ya plein de choses
qu'en plein de subtilités comme ça que
c'est essayer en fait assez difficile de
trouver les traductions des différentes
souvent parce que ce sont même pas des
traductions exact de dire par exemple
entre la notion de critères d'accueil
est non j'ai rapidement parlé dans
l'épisode précédent et la notion de
régularisation de régression l'aso qui
sont vraiment les concepts équivalent du
machine learning
en fait ils sont pas totalement
équivalent des petites subtilités mais
de façon assez intéressante si on essaie
de regarder un peu de loin et qu'on
essaie de regarder la philosophie la
logique derrière toutes ces idées on se
rend compte qu'il ya une idée assez
commune un peu plus profonde qui est que
les modèles trop complexes font
généralement de la surinterprétation et
que pour lutter contre cette sur
interprétation d'une certaine manière il
ya une certaine forme de principe de
parcimonie de rasoir d'occam qui est
utile et c'est assez amusant de voir ces
2 approche complètement différente ces
documents mais une communauté qui se
parlent pas forcément énormément
convergé vers ce même principe de
parcimonie de rasoir d'occam ceci dit si
je vais devait un peu caricaturée
l'opposition entre béziers et fréquente
east c'est que je pense que les me
semble j'espère que nathan une crise
tant vous me contredire si je me trompe
mais je me semble vraiment tout cas
c'est ce que tristan et qui dans son
commentaire
il me semble vraiment qu'elle satisfait
fréquentes east voit les statistiques
qu'il développe comme une espèce de
boîte à outils et il faut essayer de
trouver les bons outils à appliquer au
bon moment en fonction d'eux est ce
qu'il ya vraiment un risque par exemple
de paradoxes et simpson ou est-ce que
l'échantillon est assez grand à ce que
les données ressemble suffisamment une
mode normal en fonction de ce qu'on
observe en fait le statisticien d'une
certaine manière choisir les bons outils
de sa boîte à outils pour résoudre le
problème
alors que si on est bayésiens moi je
suis vraiment profondément bayésiens je
me dis que l'intervention humaine et pas
forcément souhaitable est ce que je veux
comprendre c'est aussi comment est-ce
que cet humain va choisir les outils
qu'ils utilisent et en particulier ce
qui n'est pas possible d'avoir un
système totalement automatisés c'est
vraiment l'idée d'une machine learning
et de l'intelligence artificielle c'est
d'avoir un processus qui choisi de
lui-même les bons outils à utiliser au
bon moment et est ce que le bail vient
au moins prétend c'est qu'une certaine
manière il existe un outil ultime qui
est la formule de belz et que tous ses
autres outils sont en fait des façons de
faire du bricolage pour à proximité la
formule de base ce qui est parfaitement
utile cela dit en passant
puisque la formule de baisse requiert ce
en des temps de calcul qui sont
déraisonnables
bref tout ça pour dire que même si on
est ultra valises en bois rebelles un
extrémiste comme je le suis ça veut pas
dire du tout que je rejette la boîte à
outils des fréquentes east pas du tout
cette boîte à outils est absolument
nécessaire et indispensable parce que le
bassin en pratique est limitée par ces
puissances de calcul et qu'il lui faut
du coup absolument une boîte à outils
pour essayer d'approcher cette fameuse
formule de baisse
mais tout ça bien sûr on en reparlera
mais pas aujourd'hui
5 beaucoup nous signale la différence
entre corrélation et causalité qui est
une différence c'est vraiment honteux
l'on voit la vidéo de la statistique
expliqué à mon chat pour vraiment faire
cette distinction la corrélation n'est
pas causalité on ne le dira décidément
jamais assez ceci dit j'ai envie de
pousser le raisonnement un peu plus loin
et vous demander qu'est ce que vraiment
la causalité qu est ce qu on entend
vraiment par causalité en fait c'est un
de ces mots qui est très courant dans le
langage quotidien
mais en fait c'est un homme charmant qui
en fait à ces problématiques
parfois on dit de la causalité que c'est
quelque chose c'est un espèce devient
logique c'est d'ailleurs à cause b6
lorsqu'on a à alors on a b et jouant
volontairement vers cette vidéo de
monsieur fille qui part du motus poney
ce qui est un peu la formalisation
logique de ce à cause b sauf qu'en fait
comme thibaut l'expliquer également très
bien en fait eu un lien logique à
implique b ne correspond pas toujours à
ce qu'on pense intuitivement comme étant
de la causalité tout ça en langage basé
en profiter ça correspond à dire que la
probabilité de baie saint jean a est
proche de 1
et il ya des balises 1 qui vont
commenter ça comme définition
réalité ou à plus ou moins souvent avec
un petit 1 robin ce qu'on appelle sont
les réseaux by their notamment mais en
fait ce lien de causalité en fait très
problématique il est loin d'être évident
qu'il soit quelque chose de fondamental
par exemple dans l'univers ce qui a
vraiment des liens de causalité
fondamentaux dans l'univers et encore
c'est pas évident et par exemple si je
prends la rai tv générale d'einstein et
mal l'univers a tendance à exister tout
comme un blog où il ya des corrélations
entre différents événements mais est ce
qu'il ya vraiment des liens de cause à
effet
c'est pas évident en fait il me semble
qu'un bon barisien dois dire que un lien
de causalité
c'est avant tout un modèle une façon de
penser le monde et ce modèle du monde
imaginez qu eddie ce lien de cause à
effet ça peut être une hypothèse utile à
faire pour pouvoir raisonner avec le
monde
mais encore une fois j'insiste sur le
fait que tous les modèles sont faux
certains sont utiles du coup la question
du magasin ce n'est pas est-ce que ce
lien de cause à effet est vrai la
question du gardien c est ce qu il est
utile ou tino à vancouver par exemple
des prédictions elle j'espère que
j'avais aimé cet épisode ce concept de
facteurs de confusion est incroyablement
pied lieu quand ça sera conduit à
tellement de statistiques qui sont
interprétées à la va vite et qui
conduisent souvent à des conclusions qui
sont complètement erroné parce qu'on
nommait l'étude de des facteurs de
confusion là j'espère que ce qu'il fera
aussi pas mal de vidéos et que tous ceux
qui sont concernés par ce problème tous
les étés titien je pense que c'est
vraiment un problème important dont il
faut beaucoup parler ceci dit il je m'en
excuse je vais les laisser se prennent
deux côtés et à partir du reste de la
série je vais voilà oublier se prennent
qu'est ce que sont les facteurs de
confusion on va juste supposer que les
données d'entraînement sont
effectivement représentatif de ce qu'on
cherche vraiment à décrire et du coup
des prédictions du futur qu'on aimerait
le faire et on va se poser le problème
de comment lutter contre eux sur
interpellation dans ce cas là on va voir
que diminuer la dimension aux wc qui s
conseil de correspondants table
apprentissage statistique n'est pas du
tout la solution privilégiée par les
praticiens d'aujourd'hui et en
particulier la semaine prochaine on va
parler de ce que je vais appeler la
sagesse des forêts voilà c'est comme la
sagesse des foules mais en plus
rigoureux parce que ça parle des choix
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la ligue et à la commenter à la partager
pensez à vous abonner en tant que futurs
épisodes merci aussi pour leurs dons et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois si vous connaissez pas ce paradoxe
vous promets que vous allez trouver
vraiment perturbant et une fois que vous
la vidéo je suis sûr que vous regarderez
plus les chiffres de la même manière
quand on vous demande des statistiques
peut-être bien que les boissons light
sont dangereuses mais si ça se trouve
les gens à gauche consomme aussi
beaucoup plus d'alcool et c'est en fait
ça la cause du risque d'avc plus élevé
dans ce groupe et non la consommation de
boissons light si ça se trouve aussi le
groupe à gauche fume beaucoup plus que
celui à droite on n'utilise plus souvent
la voiture ou mange moins souvent des
fruits et légumes
[Musique]